[Music]
joe biden won the presidential election
due largely to the efforts of black
women that's a well-established
fact and now that you know black women
are always right here's a few more
things you should listen to a black
woman about
in a segment called listen to a black
woman
[Music]
listen to black women about movies no
more of those movies where a white
family takes in a destitute black child
we have enough and never need another
one and doing it the other way around
is also going to be a no for me i'm
really not trying to see ludacris find
ways to empathize with a white
supremacist
child in the words of michael jordan
them kids
next listen to black women about food
it should be free and available to
everyone all the time
i should be able to eat it non-stop
without feeling bad or sick in
any way we have the science somebody
figure it out
next dating apps you better log off that
damn phone
we are in a pandemic you do not need to
be meeting up with some strange man at a
bar so he can tell you how much he loves
david fincher
if you're lonely go get a dog next
trump i'm done talking about him next
health care it should be free for all
but
since it's not please please wear a mask
because
if you get covered you will not have the
same access to the medicines used
to make the president better when he got
it okay now i'm done talking about him
next the word irregardless the hate this
word
gets is ridiculous it's elitist it's
dumb
all words are made up language is fluid
and ever evolving relax
people but also if you pronounce the l
and salmon
i will judge you next taking your shoes
off
in public don't do that next
kombucha it's nasty but if you put a
shot of tequila in it
it's good enough to drink next
advertising mr clean can get it jolly
green giant can get it the insurance
girl can get it i have no
further takes next fashion stop looking
at magazines and runways because
everything you see came from black women
first not just the clothes on their
bodies but
the literal bodies are imitations of
blackness the lips
the thighs the hips the eyes it's not
just an
india ivory song the characteristics and
features that are now the standard of
beauty on white women
have always been what sets black women
apart if it's on fleek
black women did that including creating
the words on
fleek because kayla newman in fact did
vacations great alone but even better
with someone you love
next sex same answer
next advice for the future stay safe
flip the senate and if you're mr clean
call me
this has been listen to a black woman
[Music]
let's listen to a black woman song yeah
i i heard it it was like oh this is um
this is um it's not a song that exists
it's just his own you better listen to a
black
we're only on the seventh show but once
this thing gets started
me and tariq are going to sing all of
these you better listen to it
you better tell me who you gotta listen
to black woman
girl she would listen to you too but she
would disappoint
[Music]
[Applause]
you